sometimes big things come in small
packages this as the computer chip that
powers the modern world its story well
it's a technological fairy tale once
upon a time all computers were big the
size of a floor then a desk then allowed
by the 80s they're itching to shrink
further but there's a problem
computers are power-hungry and if you
squeeze too much processing into two
smaller space they just overheat
meanwhile in a laboratory far far away
well okay in Cambridge England a group
of engineers are trying to solve a
different problem making a faster
cheaper processor you know how we always
loads of time on long and pointless
journeys
it's the same with processors so the
Cambridge engineer has come up with a
new design of chip based on short
efficient journeys to and from memory
and a simplified set of instructions
it's all based on an American idea
called reduced instruction set computing
or risk so they build a prototype and
test it and it works which is good news
so they crack open the champagne
but then someone notices that it
shouldn't be working at all because
they're not feeding at any power their
chip is so power efficient it's working
of just the residual power from other
components a powerful processor that
doesn't need much power it's virtually
magic obviously it's not magic its
science but hey we're telling a fairy
tale here the company was a con computer
remember the BBC micro well it was the
same team acorns new chip gets the
attention of bigger players Apple
bothered to spin off a new company our
advanced RISC machines in a little barn
in Cambridge they refined their magic
chip the world takes notes too when the
Apple Newton results a handheld personal
assistant that particular branch doesn't
do so well
but it proves smaller computers are
possible
meanwhile another portable device the
mobile phone is very popular there
simple devices at first until 3G
networks make the internet available
everywhere and people ask what if phones
were smarter and had the power to
process data as well as calls and that's
when the arm ship starts bearing a new
type of fruit in 2007 the iPhone comes
along then more smartphones until the
magic chip sorry the RISC microprocessor
is at the heart of 90% of a smartphone
market so it's thanks to this unexpected
discovery that the Information Age has
arrived in everyone's pocket now we can
all serve happily ever after
[Music]
[Music]
you